j'aurais dit, ce n'est pas vrai.
Le foie gras, par définition, c'est une alimentation forcée donc un gavage,
et c'est ce que vous avez quand vous voulez du foie gras.
C'était avant que j'aille à la ferme d'Eduardo dans l'Extrémadure,
à 80 km du nord de Séville, à la frontière du Portugal.
J'ai vu personnellement un système qui est incroyablement complexe
et en même temps, comme tout ce qui est beau dans la nature,
tout à fait simple.
Et il m'a tout de suite dit,
« le travail de ma vie est de donner aux oies ce qu'elles veulent. »
Il a répété ça 50 fois pendant les deux jours que j'ai passé avec lui.
« Je suis juste là pour donner aux oies ce qu'elles veulent. »
En fait, quand je suis arrivé il était allongé avec les oies avec son portable,
en train de prendre des photos d'elles,
comme si c'était ses enfants sur la pelouse.
Stupéfiant.
Il était réellement amoureux de ses oies, il ne fait qu'un avec elles,
Il est l'homme qui murmurait à l'oreille des oies.
(Rires)
Et pendant que je lui parlais, vous savez, je pensais,
comme je suis en train de vous parler maintenant,
mais au milieu de mes questions, des questions excitées,
car plus j'en apprenais sur lui et sur son système,
plus toute cette idée devenait excitante.
Il n'arrêta pas de me faire ça.
Et j'ai pensé, bon, un juif excité de New York,
je parle un peu trop agressivement, peu importe,
alors vous savez, j'ai ralenti.
Et finalement, à la fin de la journée, je parlais comme ça:
E d u a r d o, vous voyez ?
Mais il n'a pas arrêté de faire ça.
J'ai alors compris.
Je parlais trop fort.
Donc j'ai baissé la voix.
Je lui ai posé des questions, et j'ai discuté avec lui
par l'intermédiaire d'un traducteur dans le genre de demi-chuchotement.
Et il a arrêté de faire ça.
Étonnamment, les oies qui étaient de l'autre côté de l'enclos quand j'étais là,
-- « Éloignez vous de ce gars là ! » -- (Rires)
quand j'ai baissé la voix, elles sont toutes venues tout près de nous.
Directement vers nous, comme directement ici.
Tout droit le long de la clôture.
Et la clôture était elle-même surprenante.
La clôture, la conception que nous en avons,
est totalement arriérée pour lui.
L'électricité sur cette clôture en fibres de verre
est seulement sur la face extérieure.
Il l'a fait. Il l'a inventé.
je n'ai jamais vu une telle chose, et vous?
Vous clôturez des animaux. Vous électrifiez l'intérieur de la clôture.
Lui non.
Il électrifie seulement l'extérieur.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il m'a dit qu'il avait l'impression que les oies....
et il l'a prouvé, ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit, il l'a prouvé,
que les oies se sentent manipulées quand elles sont emprisonnées
dans leurs petits enclos.
Même si elles étaient emprisonnées dans ce Jardin d'Éden
avec des figues et tout ça,
il ressentait qu'elles se sentaient manipulées.
Donc il s'est débarrassé de l'électricité,
il s'est débarrassé du courant à l'intérieur
et l'a mis à l'extérieur,
pour les protéger contre les coyotes ou d'autres prédateurs.
Et qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?
Elles mangent, et il m'a montré sur un tableau,
elles mangent environ 20 % de nourriture en plus
et ainsi alimentent leurs foies.
Le paysage est incroyable.
Je suis sérieux, cette ferme est incroyable!
C'est vraiment le Jardin d'Eden.
Il y a des figues et plein d'autres choses à portée de main.
Et l'ironie suprême est que l'Extrémadure, la région,
que signifie Extrémadure ?
Extrémadure signifie terre extrêmement dure.
Extrêmement difficile. Extrêmement dure.
Mais après quatre générations, lui et sa famille
ont littéralement transformé cette terre extrêmement dure en une terre d'abondance,
augmentant ainsi la durée de vie des oies.
Et elles sont autorisées à manger ce qu'elles veulent.
Une autre ironie, la double ironie
est qu'avec les figues et les olives,
Eduardo peut se faire plus d'argent en les vendant
qu'il s'en fait avec le foie gras.
Ça lui est égal.
Il les laisse prendre ce qu'elles veulent et il dit,
« Habituellement, c'est environ 50%. Elles sont très équitables. »
Les autres 50%, il les prend et les vend et se fait de l'argent dessus.
Une partie de son revenu pour sa ferme.
Une grosse partie de son revenu pour sa ferme.
Mais il ne le contrôle jamais.
« Elle prennent ce qu'elles veulent,
Elle me laissent le reste et je le vends. »
Son plus grand obstacle, réellement, est le marché,
qui demande de nos jours des foies gras jaunes et brillants.
C'est comme ça que j'ai été formé.
Vous voulez savoir ce qu'est un bon foie gras,
il doit être brillant et jaune.
C'est l'indication que c'est le meilleur foie gras.
Eh bien, parce qu'il ne leur soumet pas à une alimentation forcée,
parce qu'il ne les gave pas avec d'énorme quantité de maïs,
leurs foies sont presque gris.
Ou bien ils l'étaient.
Mais il a trouvé cette plante sauvage appelée Lupin arborescent.
Partout dans l'Extrémadure il y a des Lupins arborescents.
Il a pris des graines pour en semer,
Il les a plantées partout sur ses 120 km² de domaine.
Et les oies adorent le Lupin arborescent.
Pas pour l'arbuste, mais pour les graines.
Et quand elles mangent les graines, leur foie devient jaune.
Une jaune radiocatif. (Rires)
Un jaune brillant. (Rires)
Un foie gras jaune qui est d'une des meilleures qualités que j'ai jamais vue.
(Rires)
Alors j'écoute tout ça, vous savez, et je me demande,
est-ce que ce gars dit la vérité ? Fait-il vraiment ce qu'il dit ?
Car il avait vraiment l'air d'avoir réponse à tout,
et c'était toujours la nature.
Ce n'était jamais lui.
Et je me disais... j'ai toujours été un petit peu
surpris par les gens qui rejettent tout acte de réussite.
Car ils veulent vraiment qu'on leur prête attention, pas vrai ?
Mais il rejetait tout acte de son ingéniosité
et mettait tout au crédit du travail avec son terrain.
Alors j'étais un peu méfiant,
mais au fur et à mesure, j'absorbais tout ce qu'il dit.
Et nous sommes assis là, et j'entends [frappe dans ses mains]
à distance, alors je regarde dans cette direction.
Et il saisit mon bras et celui du traducteur,
nous baisse sous un arbuste et dit « Regardez ça. »
« Chut » me dit-il pour la 500eme fois.
« Chut, regardez ça. » (Rires)
Alors cet escadron d'oies approche.
[frappe dans ses mains]
Et elles deviennent de plus en plus bruyantes, juste au dessus de nous.
Et comme en approche d'un aéroport, elles nous ont dépassé
puis sont repassées, encore et encore.
Puis elles ont volé en cercle.
Et ses oies sont en train d'appeler les oies sauvages.
[frappe dans ses mains]
Et les oies sauvages descendent.
Et ça devenait de plus en plus bruyant, elles volaient en cercle
et elles ont atterri.
Et je me suis juste dit « C'est impossible ! »
(Rires)
C'est vraiment impossible !
Et je regarde Eduardo, qui est au bord des larmes en voyant ça,
et je dis, « Tu es en train de me dire que tes oies disent aux oies sauvages
de leur rendre visite ? »
Et il a dit « Non, non, non.
Elles sont venues pour rester. »
Elle sont venues pour rester ?
(Rires)
Mais l'ADN d'une oie lui indique de voler vers le sud en hiver, pas vrai ?
C'est ce que je lui ai dit. « Ce n'est pas ce qu'elles font ?
Voler vers le sud pendant l'hiver et revenir au nord quand il fait chaud ? »
Il a dit « Non, non, non.
Leur ADN cherche les conditions qui sont favorables à la vie.
Au bonheur.
Elles le trouvent ici.
Elles n'ont besoin de rien d'autre. »
Elles s'arrêtent. Elles s'accouplent avec les oies domestiques,
et son troupeau continue.
Pensez-y pendant une minute.
C'est brillant, n'est-ce pas ?
Imaginez... je ne sais pas, imaginez une ferme de cochons
comme dans le nord de la Californie,
et un sanglier vient dans une ferme industrielle
et décide d'y rester.
(Rires)
Alors quel goût ça a ?
J'ai finalement goûté avant de partir.
Il m'a amené au restaurant de son voisin
et il m'a servi de son foie gras, du confit de foie gras.
C'était incroyable.
Et bien sûr le problème en disant ça, c'est que
vous savez, à ce stade on fait des hyperboles très facilement.
Et je voudrais faire une métaphore, mais j'en ai réellement aucune.
J'étais tellement accro à ses idées,
qu'il aurait pu me servir des plumes d'oie et j'aurais pensé,
ce type est un génie, vous voyez ?
Je suis à ce point amoureux de lui.
Mais c'était réellement le meilleur foie gras de ma vie.
Tellement, que je ne pense pas avoir mangé un foie gras avant ce moment.
J'ai mangé quelque chose qu'on appelait foie gras.
Mais c'était une transformation. Une réelle transformation.
Et je vous dis, je ne m'y tiendrais peut-être pas,
mais je pense que je ne mettrai plus jamais de foie gras dans un menu
à cause de cette découverte culinaire avec Eduardo.
C'était doux, c'était onctueux.
ça avait toutes les qualités du foie gras,
mais sa graisse était intègre et honnête.
Et on pouvait sentir les herbes, on pouvait sentir les épices.
Et j'ai retenu... vous savez, je le jure devant Dieu, j'ai senti de l'anis.
J'étais sûr de ça.
Et je ne suis pas un super dégustateur.
Mais je peux sentir des choses.
Il y a 100% d'anis étoilé là dedans.
Et il a dit, « Non. »
Alors j'ai énoncé toute la liste des épices,
et finalement, c'était, bon, du sel et du poivre,
pensant qu'il avait salé et poivré ses foies.
Mais non.
Il prend le foie quand il récolte les foie gras,
Il les met dans un pot.
et il les confit.
Pas de sel, pas de poivre, pas d'huile, pas d'épices.
Quoi ?
Nous sommes revenus pour une dernière visite de la ferme,
et il m'a montré des poivriers sauvages
et des plantes qu'il a placé dans sa ferme pour la salinité.
Il n'a pas besoin du sel ni du poivre.
Et il n'a pas besoin d'épices, parce qu'il a un mélange d'herbes et de parfums
que ses oies adorent manger.
Je me suis tourné vers lui à la fin du repas,
et c'est une question que j'ai posée plusieurs fois,
mais il ne m'avait jamais répondu directement,
mais j'ai dit, « Mais voyons, vous êtes en Espagne,
quelques-uns des meilleurs chefs cuisiniers dans le monde sont --
Ferran Adria, le chef cuisinier prépondérant dans le monde aujourd'hui,
n'est pas si loin de vous.
Comment se fait-il que tu ne lui aies donné ça?
Comment se fait-il que personne n'a réellement entendu parlé de toi ? »
Et c'est peut être à cause du vin,
ou peut être bien à cause de mon excitation,
Il m'a répondu directement et il a dit,
« Parce que aucun chef cuisinier ne mérite mon foie gras. »
(Rires)
Et il avait raison.
Il a raison.
Les chefs prennent des foies gras et le font de leur propre façon.
Ils créent un plat
où tous les ingrédients sont choisis par eux.
Avec Eduardo, c'est l'expression de la nature.
Et comme il disait, à juste titre,
c'est un don de Dieu, où Dieu dit, tu as fait un bon travail.
Facile.
Je rentre alors chez moi, Je suis dans l'avion avec mon petit calepin noir
et j'ai pris, voyez vous, des pages et des pages de notes là-dessus.
J'étais réellement touché.
Et dans le coin d'une de mes notes,
cette note disait, quand j'ai demandé,
que pensez-vous du foie gras conventionnel?
Que pensez-vous du foie gras que
99.99999 % du monde mange ?
Il a dit « Je pense que c'est une insulte à l'histoire. »
Et j'ai écrit, insulte à l'histoire.
Je suis dans l'avion, et là je m'arrache les cheveux.
Je me dis, pourquoi je n'ai pas poursuivi sur cette réponse ?
Qu'est ce que ça signifie ?
Une insulte à l'histoire.
J'ai alors fait des recherches quand je suis rentré,
et voilà ce que j'ai trouvé.
L'histoire du foie gras.
Les Hébreux ont inventé le foie gras.
C'est l'histoire réelle.
L'histoire vraie.
Par accident.
Ils cherchaient une alternative au schmaltz.
Ils en avaient marre de la graisse de poulet.
Ils étaient en train de chercher une alternative.
Et ils ont vu qu'en automne il y avait une graisse naturelle,
belle, douce, et délicieuse chez les oies.
Ils les ont abattues, et ont utilisé la graisse pendant l'hiver pour la cuisine.
Les pharaons ont eu vent de ça --
C'est la vraie histoire ; directement d'internet.
Le pharaon l'avait... (Rires)
Je jure devant Dieu.
(Rires)
Le pharaon en a entendu parlé et a voulu goûter.
Il l'a gouté et en est tombé amoureux.
Il a commencé à en demander.
Et il n'en voulait pas qu'en automne, il en voulait toute l'année.
Il a exigé que les Hébreux en fournissent assez pour tout le monde.
Les Hébreux, qui craignaient pour leur survie,
ont dû trouver une idée ingénieuse,
pour essayer de satisfaire les souhaits du pharaon, bien sûr.
Et ils ont inventé, quoi ? Le gavage.
Ils ont inventé le gavage dans un moment de peur pour leurs vies,
et ils ont fourni au pharaon des foies provenant du gavage,
et ils ont gardé les bons trucs pour eux-même,
apparemment, enfin. J'y crois.
C'est l'histoire du foie gras.
et si vous y pensez,
c'est l'histoire de l'agriculture industrielle.
C'est l'histoire de ce que nous mangeons aujourd'hui.
La plupart de ce que nous mangeons aujourd'hui.
Méga-fermes, lots d'alimentation, ajouts chimiques,
des voyages sur de longues distances, les procédés agroalimentaires.
Tout ça, notre système d'alimentation.
C'est aussi une insulte à l'histoire.
C'est une insulte aux lois fondamentales de la nature
et de la biologie.
Que nous parlions du boeuf,
ou des poulets
que nous parlions du brocoli, ou des choux de Bruxelles,
ou dans le cas du New York Times, ce matin, du poisson chat --
dont le commerce de gros périclite.
Peu importe ce que c'est, c'est une mentalité
qui fait penser à General Motors.
C'est enraciné dans leur politique.
Prendre plus, vendre plus, gaspiller plus.
Et pour le futur, ça nous desservira.
Jonas Salk a une bonne citation.
Il a dit, « Si tous les insectes disparaissaient,
la vie sur la Terre telle que nous la connaissons disparaitrait en 50 ans.
Si l'être humain disparaissait, la vie sur la terre telle que nous la connaissons
serait prospère. » (Rires)
Et il a raison.
Nous avons besoin maintenant d'adopter
une nouvelle conception d'agriculture. Une réelle nouveauté.
Une conception dans laquelle nous arrêtons de traiter la planète
comme une chose où on pourrait tirer du profit.
Et arrêter de dégrader les ressources sous la fausse apparence d'avoir
une nourriture peu coûteuse.
Nous pouvons commencer en regardant ce que font les fermiers comme Eduardo.
Les fermiers qui comptent sur la nature
pour les solutions, les réponses,
plutôt que d'imposer des solutions à la nature.
Écoutez, comme le dit Janine Benyus,
l'une de mes écrivains et penseurs favoris,
« Écoutez les instructions de la nature. »
C'est ce qu'Eduardo fait, et il le fait brillamment.
Et ce qu'il m'a montré et ce qu'il a pu nous montrer, je pense,
est que ce qui est bien pour les chefs, la grande aubaine pour les chefs,
et pour les personnes soucieuses de la nourriture et de la cuisine,
est que le choix le plus écologique pour la nourriture
est aussi le choix le plus éthique pour la nourriture.
Que nous parlions des choux de Bruxelles ou du foie gras.
Et c'est aussi presque toujours, et je n'ai pas trouvé de contre exemple,
mais presque toujours, le choix le plus délicieux.
C'est un fait surprenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)